Europe is at the crossroads and and it's
undergoing an existential crisis not
only outside but also inside inside we
are under the threat of populist and
nationalist outside the restaurant who
even believe that Europe will
disintegrate further there is Putin who
wants to divide the European Union and
at the same time there is this external
threat of the political radical Islam
member states have always fair often an
in depth reform of the Union but let's
let's face the reality they are all with
our back against the wall so it's now
the moment to reform the European Union
to make it a real union and not a loose
confederation of nation-states still
based on the unanimity rule always
acting too little too late you cannot
govern a continent like Europe if you
still need your proof of all 28 member
states today the first thing to do then
a smaller less bureaucratic the real
European government of the commission of
28 but as a small Commission and then
also a European defense Union because
there is a threat from outside Union
received in in our neighborhood in
Ukraine in Syria we need also a European
border and Coast Guard to will manage
the migration flows I think that there
is no other solution for Europe then to
do this in-depth reforms you're
proposing because otherwise we're gonna
disintegrate further it happens already
with brexit other countries will could
follow we don't want a number of
institutional reforms in the Union
because we like institutional reforms we
wanted because we think that we will
have done better instruments on the
European level to tackle the challenge
that people are seeing today